advice that I would give to educators
also planning or hoping to teach the
same kind of course material or subject
would be to have somebody of the
diaspora or somebody who can relate to
the diaspora teach it it's important to
have people of the background or of the
diaspora educating it's like who better
to educate than those that have
experienced it themselves or those that
you know like come from that area so I
feel like that's probably the biggest
advice I would give I think maybe other
advice would be really making sure to
create safe spaces for students to have
conversations because I feel like we had
that in this class and that you can have
a curriculum that can be very diverse
and like can be very open but if you
don't create an environment and we're
like in which students can like openly
speak about things and openly talk about
things like it's not gonna matter and I
feel like it limits the kinds of
discussions you have and I feel like
we've had a lot of great discussions in
this class because the environment has
been it's been a safe environment you
know when people can voice their
opinions and things have gotten very
personal in this class sometimes you
know there have been one or two
instances where students that have been
left you know because they were so
emotional and so like yeah it's not it's
not just about the curriculum - it's
also about the space that you create